somebody should read the chat by the way
um i can't imagine they're just saying
easy easy
nine episodes
you see and the rest is something about
david's internet
account
what's up
if david mother david's mother ass he's
not a grinder
she wants me to be genuine yeah he's
like
you just gotta find someone at this
point it's time
yeah it's long overdue
knight f3 knight g5 knight everyone i
provoked a weakness
you don't understand this in your own
position
now bishop p3
where where are his targets
left with
nothing
like mourinho would say
if i say something i said i'm in big
trouble i say nothing
uh what should i do now
have you heard of the lotion band
feels like something i should have had
this is the best
this is the best best album of all time
he's getting flustered boys
he's not finding the way time warning
oh time warning oh good good good good
can't do one next
kingdom one queen d2 oh that was a bad
move that was a bad move back back back
f5
oh i have this
take the take the queen
check
take it take it
oh really
look at this one
look at this one three oh boy